that's right doesn't matter the year or
era we're in there's always more to talk
about when it comes to batman gonna
start out giving some love to the
sponsor of this video this video is
sponsored no stranger to this channel
this video is sponsored by nordvpn
because in this day and age traversing
the digital wonderland of the internet
it's a given even a necessity but doing
so safely that's not such a given so
nordvpn's a vpn service that looks to
help you navigate this
digital utopia or digital minefield
comparatively more safely i mean nordvpn
blocks malware written websites like i'm
a big retro gamer whether you're a retro
gamer or a pc gamer sometimes finding
that optimum homebrew to optimize your
gaming experience will take you to
websites you just don't know to get a
file you've heard is safe so i
appreciate the fact that nordvpn will
block the malware written websites and
scan downloaded files for viruses so i
can just enjoy the gaming so click the
link below go to
nordvpn.com users can get one month free
and an additional gift with the purchase
of a two-year plan risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee and thank
you once again to nordvpn for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it and now i
imagine you've come here to hear me talk
about some spoilers for the batman so
i'm going to do that that's a fair
warning for people who might be among
the uninitiated who have not seen the
batman also that's me saying i'm not
gonna have a play-by-play as always for
my spoiler talks not gonna break down
the entire movie i mean a lot happens in
this two-hour 55-minute movie that is me
saying i'm not going to touch on
everything the major plot points that
stand out to me though yeah so as the
batman starts out which is funny enough
i thought they were going one way and it
i thought they were zigging and they
zagged because you see this pov and it's
a super rich person's house and you see
this mom dad and kid and i was like okay
it's the waynes we're gonna see the
waynes again it's not the waynes though
it's the riddler's first victim he clubs
this person which
with the tool if you know what you're
looking at you have yourself your first
riddler clue in a world where nothing is
trivial when it comes to the riddler
something maybe circumstantial but i
appreciate the fact that this movie
actually did what spider-man homecoming
did where it's like okay people know the
story of the dead relative or relatives
in this case the waynes we don't have to
show it they know it let's just see
batman do stuff or vengeance his name is
funny his name is vengeance i mean he's
not batman it's batman because it's
batman to us but in the movie it's like
his name is vengeance we saw it in the
trailer but we didn't know he was
actually saying his name i'm vengeance
yeah because you know you got vengeance
and your your batman exacting vengeance
no i mean that's my name on vengeance oh
that's how people treat them they're
like hey vengeance come here all right
that's a good call vengeance all right
vengeance you coming all right vengeance
let's do this why you dressed like a bat
this is what vengeance looks like let's
saying you just have a v on your chest
right oh didn't you see the mini series
v stands for victory not vengeance okay
it's just getting weird now i did like
the breakdown of it showing how bruce
wayne deals with the fact that he's been
so nocturnal for the past two years he
has a journal he takes notes just to
keep his days in order as someone who
has always been a night owl has
continued to this day there's no fixing
this internal clock yet your days do
bleed together it's actually really
smart to make a journal
but i'm not going to
because i just i know me and this movie
has a lot going on in it man like oswald
cobblepods the penguin which colin
farrell crushed it in this movie and
then that leads to showing catwoman
selena kyle's working in his
establishment to get close to carmine
falcone which i didn't even know he was
in this movie i didn't know carmine
falcone was in this movie i didn't know
john tutturo played him in this movie
both pleasant surprises which shows that
in my spoiler-free video i was like well
there are huge plot points i just can't
talk about so that's why i do videos
like this i thought john tuttura was
great but then the execution of having
him in this movie was great too he
didn't feel like carmine falcone from
batman begins it was actually very much
in line with long halloween it's great
to have the same character but not feel
redundant it's definitely its own thing
talented filmmaking right there a lot of
characters in this movie that were
amazing and robert pattinson was good in
the movie too has some things to say
about the rendition of batman in this
movie this version of batman how it
didn't fully feel like batman for me
take it easy sweetheart not saying
robert pattinson's bad in it the best i
can say it is
batman in this movie feels so different
from any other on-screen batman i've
seen in a world that does feel in line
with batman you look at gotham in this
movie best rendition of gotham i've seen
on screen but that felt like gotham
oswald cobblepot felt like penguin
selena kyle felt like catwoman batman
felt like what they did with heath
ledger's joker and actually it's the
same argument i've seen people like
heath ledger was great in the movie but
they don't dig that version of joker
because it doesn't feel like joker to
them it doesn't feel like comic book
joker feels like a version of the joker
that was made to feel like a guy in the
real world was just sick in the head
painted his face he was a mass murderer
a joker that we could see in the world
sans the comic book element or it might
be more apt to compare this execution to
joaquin phoenix's joker which was even
more of a reimagining of the joker
character and that's what batman
specifically in this movie feels like it
feels like what it would look like if he
turned on the news and saw a guy running
around in a mask and a cape running down
alleyways you'd be like is that guy
trying to be batman no dick i'm
vengeance it felt very much in line with
that which is a really bold move i'll
say that that's a big swing to take a
batman that doesn't feel like this
mythical batman feels like a person who
just put on a costume was like i'm a
fight crime that point was really
hammered home in the movie when he
glided through the airs you know like i
like seeing batman with his cape and
he's all gliding no not this batman not
vengeance he has a legit flying squirrel
wingsuit that is how he glides through
the air it does grow on you as a call
they made in this movie were like okay
they're taking in a new direction and if
they spend a trilogy getting him to feel
like this mythical batman i'm totally
down because i thought the world was
amazing and they just spent a trilogy
getting spider-man to feel like
spider-man so you know that's kind of
it's a thing nowadays but i suppose i
found some connection in my head when i
thought of that you remember that mortal
kombat reboot or mortal kombat
reimagining or short film back in 2011
2011
time flies where reptile was a cannibal
with a skin condition baraka was a
plastic surgeon who put blades on his
forearms that was mortal kombat that
took mortal kombat characters and it was
like okay let's say they were real in
still kind of unrealistic ways but we'll
take all the magic and [ __ ] out of it
and just make them people with skin
diseases and plastic surgeons who are
crazy kind of had a eureka moment when i
made that connection between these two
properties mortal kombat rebirth and the
batman and how really they aim to do the
same thing and i
enjoyed it when i saw it in mortal
kombat in fact you look at the riddler
the riddler is in the same way
that reimagining of what would the
riddler be if he was actually in the
world there's a part of me that was like
i could go for riddler being 20 less
eccentric
i don't know where i got that arbitrary
ass number i'm just saying a little less
because i like collected riddler but if
someone was crazy enough to be riddler
he would probably be as unstable as
riddler in this movie is it's funny
because i feel like he wasn't unmasked
he wasn't caught until much later in the
movie probably comparatively because it
was like two hours into the movie but
that still means we have about an hour
left of the movie i don't even know if
that time frame is not like i was
checking my watch which is a good sign
but riddler's plan in this movie is to
basically peel back and expose the
corrupt [ __ ] behind the facade of
the people in power that's where i come
into conflict with the concept of this
riddler this riddler being a riddler but
if he was in the real world our world
because in our world we wouldn't need
the riddler you just let politicians and
people in power keep talking and their
[ __ ] just ends up showing itself so
no riddler needed but i can get behind
this what makes the villain great is you
can get behind the idea of exposing lies
and corruption but he's going about it
all the wrong ways including murder and
mass murder shootout at the end of the
movie there were some scenes in this
movie like this movie from the trailer
it was like oh it looks like seven with
batman then they get in the riddler's
place and i was like this is like
straight up from seven i do wish i had
seen more andy circus as alfred and you
can make the argument well you've seen
alfred and bruce wayne in movies before
we get the relationship but not this
alfred and bruce wayne you're looking at
michael caine he was the butler he cared
for this kid and then that kid became a
man who left trained with ninjas came
back and then alfred met him at the
airport and he had his back until the
end where he was like i failed you i
failed you this alfred trained bruce
wayne to fight he actually trained him
to be batman i will say since alfred
felt like he was kind of in the
background in this movie he didn't feel
like a main support character that lack
of screen time caused me to think when
alfred got blown up i thought he might
have actually died can't say i've
experienced that in another batman movie
i thought well this whole new direction
and you know it's a whole new take on
batman alfred could die when bruce wayne
gets to the hospital and he's told just
touch and go and we're hoping he pulls
through i'm like okay alfred will be
fine but it wasn't like in batman arkham
origins where you're supposed to believe
alfred might be in peril maybe he'll die
and it never crosses your mind not for a
second because you're like this is a
prequel to arkham asylum in arkham city
and he is alive in there so he's gonna
be fine well as much as i wanted to see
more alfred and i wanted more of that
connection between alfred and bruce
wayne and this dynamic for this take on
them it did lead to me being like alfred
might have died i've never felt that
before ever so going to the end of this
movie the riddler has this plan that
actually
mostly comes to happen it gets down to
the wire here batman finds out too
little too late riddler's plan because
he doesn't know what that thing is that
lays carpet down and puts it
under the wall
and obviously neither do i so i guess
gotham would be [ __ ] if i was a
protector people be on youtube videos
like he doesn't fully feel like batman
feels like a youtuber dressed up like
batman so these detonations go off in
these key parts of gotham which makes
the harbor just come in and flood gotham
and then the riddler on a super dark web
chat room has gotten a lot of friends
that all dress up like him and they're
up there with sniper rifles i'm just
gonna start popping shots which i was
like okay
so there's gonna be some hard blue check
mark rage about this
there should be if there's consistency
remember when twitter thought that
there's gonna be some mass shootings and
movie theaters because joker was a movie
and it didn't happen now there's a
batman movie with an actual mass
shooting i suppose if there's not blue
checkmark outrage i'll give them props
for chilling out over the course of the
past couple years i'm just saying though
if consistency is consistent
and it never is on twitter long story
short batman saves the days doesn't
change the fact that gotham got really
[ __ ] with a lot of water i do hope in
the next movie zoe kravitz comes back as
selena kyle because i thought she was
great in the movie i mean i don't know
if she has a reason for her to come back
but i hope she does come back selena
kyle doesn't always have to be catwoman
because of the carmine falcone thing for
many decades where she did her catwoman
thing not because of that so we'll see
what happens oh yeah the ends the very
end riddler's captured he's in his cell
then you hear someone chattering in the
next cell at him and it's clearly joker
but not like joker or joker new joker we
have ourselves another joker that's
going to happen which i'm i'm not really
sold on another joker right now it's
probably the execution of it you know i
was just like oh hey joker and this
other person
it's like oh i guess they're bringing
joker in again i i enjoy things like
that being events was like oh joaquin
phoenix is jokered it's a big deal and
it's this big thing that's happening and
you're leading up to it because it's
it's the [ __ ] joker keith ledger
being cast as joker was a huge part of
the build-up of the dark knight you know
joker
i get why they're having joker in this
world so soon because the movie joker
which isn't this joker but is still the
character is the highest grossing rated
art film of all time well i'm of a
different mindset from studios you know
i enjoy such things being events it's
the lack of having that thing so often
you know the years in between those
moments where we have a new joker that
makes joker special but hollywood
studios have a very different mindset
they're like oh that movie made a lot of
money sweet here's all the joker stuff
and that's what they're gonna do that's
what they did with star wars you know
star wars used to be this thing it was
just like oh every three years or so we
get a star wars movie and then it was
like every year you have your star wars
movie just kind of like oh okay new star
wars is happening
i know it ceases to be special looks
like they're gonna do that with joker
different studios same hollywood bubble
so it's going to happen the same way for
nothing else this kind of joker cameo
reminded me of the harley quinn cameo in
arrow it was like the suet they were
doing suicide squad and arrow i think it
was season two otherwise known as back
when arrow was really good it was harley
quinn's silhouette behind the door and
amanda waller hits the door and that's
all you get it kind of reminded me of
that which worked for arrow
in that made-for-tv kind of way in a tv
show kind of way but this feeling like a
tv show thing it just didn't really land
with me but in the end the batman is
it's gonna range like this for you
you're either gonna like it or love it i
can't see a lot of people hating the
movie you know to hate it be like oh it
sucks i mean some will but that's not
gonna be most of the conversation most
of the conversation's gonna be like okay
so that movie that was good let's talk
about that all right so the batman now
that it's out have you seen it what did
you think about it and how did you like
the portrayal of batman the character in
this movie did he feel like batman to
you did he not are you cool with it it's
a conversation whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you